lois lane is superman's girlfriend
a pulitzer prize-winning reporter and a
mom
though this character is as old as
superman himself
there's still a lot about her most
people don't know
this is her story one dazzling daily
planet scoop
at a time lois lane was created by jerry
segal
and joe shuster right alongside superman
himself
her characterization sprang from a
number of places
including 1930s movies and siegel's own
wife
back in 1988 the superman writer shared
that he wanted lois to be a hard-nosed
working girl
rather than a damsel to be saved by
superman he based her partially on the
character of torchy blaine
a fictional journalist who searched for
scoops in depression-era double features
he told time magazine what inspired me
in the creation was glenda farrell
the movie star who portrayed torchy
blaine a gutsy beautiful headline
hunting reporter
in a series of exciting motion pictures
because the name of the actress
lola lane appealed to me i called my
character lois lane
strangely the characterization of lois
is amazingly like the real-life
personality of my lovely wife
siegel and his wife joanne were actually
brought together by
superman she modeled for schuster's
original drawings of lois lane
and went on to marry siegel over a
decade later
even in the earliest superman comics the
dynamic at play between lois lane
and superman is multifaceted lois is
frequently unimpressed by her co-worker
clark kent only to be dazzled when she
is saved
later by the heroic superman this is
established in action comics number one
when a date between clark and lois goes
haywire
the date didn't exactly start on good
terms either
lois accepts the date out of boredom
saying she'll go out with clark
for a change when a guy interrupts their
dance later that evening
she excoriates clark for not standing up
to the bully
when lois steps in and slaps the jerk
clark
mutters his approval under his breath
good for you lois
but of course he follows up in a much
louder voice
telling her to stop he loves her for
being the kind of woman who can't love
the man he's pretending to be
a juicy drama fans have loved ever since
lois character is built on the tension
between her competitive relationship
with clark kent and her desire to
unearth
superman's identity on the one hand
clark
kent is her rival at work the pair
regularly duke it out
to land scoops and earn the favor of
their bosses
at the daily planet but of course lois's
journalistic instincts come into
conflict with her burgeoning attraction
to superman
she's into him but she just can't stop
wanting to unearth the real identity of
metropolis's defender
the mystery surrounding superman and
clark kent
is a key component of lois's stories in
the first few years of the character's
history
frequently in these stories superman has
to fight off the villain of the week
while hiding his identity from lois
happen to be in niagara falls
and clark clark is not around as
usual
superman changed with the times and so
did lois lane
the 50s and 60s marked a dramatic shift
in mainstream comics toward the cosmic
sci-fi plot lines flourished and alien
nemeses
rained down on metropolis while superman
was off
fighting stranger and stranger threats
lois launched her
own incredibly successful series
superman's girlfriend
lois lane was one of the best selling
titles of the early 60s
frequently showcasing the reporter
hatching bigger and bigger plots to
convince
superman to marry her lois was rebooted
after dc's
seminal 80s event crisis on infinite
earth
in many ways this was a return to form
the wannabe wife
vanished and the hard-nosed reporter of
the 40s was
restored this lois doesn't rely on
superman for rescue
and is depicted as a tough journalist
willing to put herself
in danger to get the truth out there
though lois is still enamored with
superman
and increasingly with clark he's not the
only focus of her romantic exploits
she has shown throughout the 80s and 90s
having relationships with other
metropolis bachelors
while occasionally going on dates with
kent the relationship between the pair
grows with
time in an organic way it took until
1996 for lois and clark
to finally get married they've largely
remained together
ever since the first kid lois and clark
call their own
enters their lives much like clark
entered his kansas parentses
chris kent falls to earth in a
kryptonian spacecraft
lois and clark take him in as their own
learning later that he is the child of
superman's nemesis
zod chris's arrival on earth creates a
gateway that
zod uses to travel out of the phantom
zone where he's been imprisoned
zod attacks the earth and attempts to
reclaim chris
as his son being raised by the kents
however he rebels against his biological
father
and protects lois and clark from zod
after a war between zod and earth ensues
superman is able to send
the evil kryptonian back to his prison
dimension for good
to keep zod from escaping again chris
sacrifices himself and voluntarily goes
to the phantom zone as well
years later superman and lois go on to
have a son of their own
named jonathan kent the dc universe's
current
superboy over the years writers have
found ways to make lois a little more
than human
in early takes on lois she occasionally
finds herself in possession of powers
with a shelf life
often through fabulous feats of super
science
whenever lois briefly becomes a
superhero she takes on the identity of
superwoman
and feels what it's like to live as her
ultra powerful boyfriend
generally speaking she's a fan a few
very
different takes on super-powered lois
exist as well
in a parallel timeline lois and clark
are both killed by darkseid and his
forces from the planet of apocalypse
her father sam survives and manages to
upload her consciousness
into a robotic body making her that
universe's red
tornado lois teams up with the few
surviving superheroes of earth
and works to expel darkseid and his army
other mishaps and dream sequences have
turned lois
into elastic lass green lantern and
even a bad guy from time to time in one
alternate timeline where she marries lex
luthor
she becomes the super villain leopard
lady check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite comic
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one